>> Tucker: COUPLE HOURS AGO THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" RAN A STORY
SAYING FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ IS UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION FOR PLAYING SOME
ROLE IN SEX TRAFFICKING AND
POTENTIALLY HAVING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD
GIRL.
THERE ARE VERY FEW DETAILS IN
MAJOR NEWS OUTLETS TONIGHT ABOUT
THIS STORY.
WE HAVE NO BACKGROUND ON IT AT
ALL AND NOT EVEN ANY VERY
INFORMED QUESTIONS.
INSTEAD WE HAVE INVITED
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ ON THE SHOW TO
RESPOND TO THESE STORIES AND
GIVE US HIS VIEW OF THEM.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
I APPRECIATE IT.
SO, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A SERIOUS
ALLEGATION.
TELL US WHAT THE TRUTH IS FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
>> IT IS A HORRIBLE ALLEGATION
AND IT IS A LIE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS RUNNING
A STORY THAT I HAVE TRAVELED
WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD WOMAN AND
THAT IS VERIFIABLABLY FALSE.
PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT MY TRAVEL
RECORDS AND SEE THAT THAT IS NOT
THE CASE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS AN
EXTORTION OF ME AND MY FAMILY
INVOLVING A FORMER DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OFFICIAL.
ON MARCH 16TH, MY FATHER GOT A
TEXT MESSAGE DEMANDING A MEETING
WHERE IN A PERSON DEMANDED
$25 MILLION IN EXCHANGE FOR
MAKING HORRIBLE SEX TRAFFICKING
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST ME GO AWAY.
OUR FAMILY WAS SO TROUBLED BY
THAT, WE WENT TO THE LOCAL FBI
AND THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WERE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS ATTEMPTED EXTORTION
OF A MEMBER OF CONGRESS THAT
THEY ASKED MY DAD TO WEAR A
WIRE, WHICH HE DID WITH THE
FORMER DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OFFICIAL.
TONIGHT I AM DEMANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI RELEASE THE AUDIO RECORDINGS
THAT WERE MADE UNDER THEIR
SUPERVISION AND AT THEIR
DIRECTION WHICH WILL PROVE MY
INNOCENCE AND THAT WILL SHOW
THAT THESE ALLEGATIONS AREN'T
TRUE.
THEY ARE MERELY INTENDED TO TRY
TO BLEED MY FAMILY OUT OF MONEY
AND THIS FORMER DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OFFICIAL TOMORROW WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE CONTACTED BY MY
FATHER SO THAT SPECIFIC
INSTRUCTIONS COULD BE GIVEN
REGARDING THE WIRING OF
$4.5 MILLION AS A DOWN PAYMENT
ON THIS BRIBE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A COINCIDENCE
THAT TONIGHT SOMEHOW THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" IS LEAKING THIS
INFORMATION, SMEARING ME AND
RUINING THE INVESTIGATION THAT
WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN A ONE OF
THE FORMER COLLEAGUES OF THE
CURRENT DOJ BEING BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE FOR TRYING TO EXTORT ME
AND MY FAMILY.
>> Tucker: SO A COUPLE OF
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT COME TO
MIND AND, AGAIN, JUST TO RESTATE
THIS JUST HAPPENED.
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER INFORMATION
BEYOND WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY SAID
AND YOU HAVE SAID.
FIRST OF ALL, WHO IS THIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FORMER ELM
>> Emily: EMPLOYEE WHO IS TRYING
TO EXTORT THE MONEY FROM YOU YOU
SAY.
>> HIS NAME IS DAVID McGEE.
HE WAS A TOP OFFICIAL IN THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF FLORIDA AS A
PROSECUTOR.
HE CURRENTLY WORKS AT THE BEGS
AND ELLAYNA LAW FIRM.
AS A AS A MATTER OF FACT, ONE OF
THE RECORDINGS THAT WAS MADE AT
THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REQUEST OCCURRED AT THAT
LAW FIRM AND THE MONEY THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE PAID TODAY THAT
WOULD HAVE SHOWN EVEN MORE
EVIDENCE OF DAVID McGEE'S WORK
IN THIS EXTORTION SCHEME, THAT
WAS FOILED BY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" STORY AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S WHY THIS HORRIBLE
INFORMATION AND THESE TERRIBLE
ALLEGATIONS HAVE BEEN USED THIS
EVENING.
>> Tucker: SO -- AND I WILL GET
TO THE INVESTIGATION IN JUST A
SECOND.
BUT YOU ARE SAYING THAT DAVID
McGEE WAS MOTIVATED BY GREED.
HE WAS TRYING TO EXTORT MONEY
FROM YOUR FAMILY?
THAT'S HIS MOTIVATION, YOU ARE
SAYING?
>> I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
DEMAND FOR MONEY IN EXCHANGE FOR
A COMMITMENT THAT HE COULD MAKE
THIS INVESTIGATION GO AWAY ALONG
WITH HIS CO-CONSPIRATORRERS.
THEY EVEN CLAIMED TO HAVE
SPECIFIC CONNECTIONS INSIDE THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE
THEY WERE PROMISING THAT JOE
BIDEN WOULD PARDON ME.
OBVIOUSLY I DON'T NEED A PARDON.
I'M NOT SEEKING A PARDON.
I HAVE NOT DONE ANYTHING
IMPROPER OR WRONG.
BUT WHAT I AM TROUBLED BY IS THE
REAL MOTIVATION.
TED LOU IS CALL FOR ME TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I BELIEVE WE ARE IN ANNER ARE A
OF OUR POLITICS, TUCKER, WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SMEARED TO TAKE THEM
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION.
I'M NOT THE ONLY PERSON ON
SCREEN RIGHT NOW WHO HAS BEEN
FALSELY ACCUSED OF A TERRIBLE
SEX ACT.
YOU WERE ACCUSED OF SOMETHING
YOU DID NOT DO SO YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS FEELS LIKE.
YOU KNOW THE PAIN IT CAN BRING
TO YOUR FAMILY AND IT PUTS
PEOPLE ON DEFENSE WHEN YOU ARE
ACCUSED OF SOMETHING SO
SALACIOUS AND AWFUL BUT IT DID
NOT HAPPEN, IT IS NOT TRUE THE
FACT IT IS THE BASIS TO EXTORT
MY FAMILY TELLS A LOT.
IF THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL RELEASE THE TAPES
THAT THEY ARE IN POSSESSION OF,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL SEE
WHAT IS REALLY GOING ON.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST REFERRED TO
A MENTALLY ILL VIEWER WHO
ACCUSED ME OF A SEX CRIME 20
YEARS AGO AND, OF COURSE, IT WAS
NOT TRUE.
I NEVER MET THE PERSON.
BUT I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT
BEING ACCUSED FALSELY THAT BEING
ACCUSED FALSELY IS ONE OF THE
WORST THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN AND
YOU DO SEE IT A LOT.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE
INVESTIGATION YOU SAY IT WAS OR
IS UNDERWAY.
THERE WAS AN INVESTIGATION.
WHAT IS THE BASIS OF THAT
INVESTIGATION?
WHAT IS THE ALLEGATION THAT
REALLY NOT VERY CLEAR FROM THESE
NEWS STORIES.
>> YEAH, AGAIN, I ONLY KNOW WHAT
I HAVE READ IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
I CAN SAY THAT ACTUALLY YOU AND
I WENT TO DINNER ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO, YOUR WIFE WAS THERE AND I
BROUGHT A FRIEND OF MINE, YOU
WILL REMEMBER HER.
AND SHE WAS ACTUALLY THREATENED
BY THE FBI, TOLD THAT IF SHE
WOULDN'T COP TO THE FACT THAT
SOMEHOW I WAS INVOLVED IN SOME
PAY FOR PLAY SCHEME THAT SHE
COULD FACE TROUBLE AND SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHO
ARE TRYING TO SMEAR ME, YOU
KNOW, PROVIDING FOR FLIGHTS AND
HOTEL ROOMS FOR PEOPLE THAT YOU
ARE DATING WHO ARE OF LEGAL AGE
IS NOT A CRIME AND I'M JUST
TROUBLED THAT LACK OF ANY SORT
OF LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION INTO
ME WOULD THEN PER MUTE, WOULD
THEN CONVERT INTO THIS EXTORTION
ATTEMPT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T REMEMBER THE
WOMAN YOU ARE SPEAKING OF OR THE
CONTEXT AT ALL, HONESTLY BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHO -- SO
THEY ARE SAYING THERE IS A
17-YEAR-OLD GIRL WHO YOU HAD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH; IS THAT TRUE?
AND WHO IS THIS GIRL?
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT THE
"NEW YORK TIMES"?
>> THE PERSON DOESN'T EXIST.
I HAVE NOT HAD A RELATIONSHIP
WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD.
THAT IS TOTALLY FALSE.
THE ALLEGATION IS AS I READ IN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS I HAVE
TRAVELED WITH SOME 17-YEAR-OLD
IN SOME RELATIONSHIP.
THAT IS FALSE AND RECORDS WILL
BEAR THAT OUT TO BE FALSE.
>> Tucker: HOW LONG HAS THIS
INVESTIGATION BEEN GOING ON, DO
YOU KNOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU FIRST
INFORMED OF IT?
>> YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I REALLY SAW
THIS AS A DEEPLY TROUBLING
CHALLENGE FOR MY FAMILY ON MARCU
KNOW, TALKING ABOUT A MINOR AND
THAT THERE WERE PICTURES OF ME
WITH CHILD PROSTITUTES.
THAT'S